[Applaudissements]
tous il ya un peu plus d'un an
forfait face à l'une
reuss crise existentielle j'ai expliqué
les médecins et les spécialistes sans
réussir à trouver vraiment de réponse et
un jour par hasard je me suis retrouvée
chez une psychologue qui m'a fait passer
un test de qi et là j'ai découvert à 21
ans que j'étais surdoué
ouah j'étais surdoué quand j'ai appris
cette nouvelle j'étais très content
j'étais très content pas parce que
j'étais surdoué pas parce que j'étais
j'avais un qi supérieur à un certain
chiffre non j'étais très content parce
que la psychologue m'a expliqué point
par point ce que ça faisait que d'être
surdoué tous que ça entraîner dans
l'enfance etc
et donc j'ai découvert mon décalage par
rapport au monde à 21 ans 21 ans qu'on
disait à mes parents monsieur barge
madame barge votre enfant il est bizarre
mais bon il a des bonnes notes donc ça
va je 21 ans que je ne comprenais pas
comment les gens fonctionner et mon
incapacité à rentrer en contact avec eux
et donc quand j'ai découvert cette
pierre angulaire de mes problèmes
eh ben j'ai été très content très très
très content et quand je suis très
content je vais voir mes amis je vais
voir mes proches je vais leur expliquer
pourquoi je suis très content et donc je
leur ai dit voilà je suis surdouée et
c'est super et donc j'ai fait face à
plein d'idées reçues que j'attendais pas
du tout la plus pâle la chose qu'on m'a
répété majoritairement c'est pas bon
mais tu es intelligent toi et c'est vrai
que je dois vous avez quelque chose
cette question je me l'étais poser aussi
en effet deux semaines avant le résultat
de nos tests de qi j'ai reçu la
fabuleuse note de 1 925 sur vingt en
mécanique générale et cette année mais
notre tourne plus autour de 7 que de 17
alors que pour moi et pour beaucoup je
pense un surdoué c'est un enfant qui a
13 ans enseigne à l'université de
mathématiques qui à ses heures perdues
réalise des rubik's cube avec ses pieds
vous voyez l'idée mais c'est une
réaction quand on fait face à cette
réaction là c'est pas difficile à vivre
c'est non on en rigole etc il ya
d'autres personnes on rend compte par
exemple comme maxime louguet que vous
avez entendu tout à l'heure qui vous
disent qu'est ce que c'est
l'intelligence au final intelligence
avec un grand i le quotient intellectuel
et donc ça permet de débattre un peu de
l'intelligence etc
ces deux idées reçues là c'est très
intéressant et c'est très surprenant à
avoir puis à d'autres idées reçues il ya
d'autres réactions auxquelles on fait
face qui sont beaucoup plus compliquées
il y en a certains qui rejette en bloc
la surdouée ans qui vous disent ça sont
les surdoués ça n'existe pas ça a été
inventé pour les gens riches pour se
satisfaire pour concevoir plus
intelligent et puis on a d'autres qui
pense que l'intelligence et un est une
nécessité en soi et donc va il se dompte
cette espèce est un espèce de don de
dieu d'être surdoué et donc les gens
deviennent un peu jaloux du fait que
vous ayez surdoué deviennent un peu
agressive envers vous alors que alors
qu'il ya aucune raison d'être
et donc j'ai découvert que j'étais
surdoué j'ai découvert toutes ces idées
reçues je suis sûr que parmi vous vous
pensez ça vous pensez même d'autres
choses et y en a plus il ya plein de
réactions différentes mais j'arrivais
pas à voir pourquoi mon idée du surdoué
et pourquoi ce que j'étais moi diverger
beaucoup et donc j'ai fait des
recherches j'ai fait des recherches
scientifiques j'ai fait des recherches
dans des livres j'ai discuté avec des
psychologues avec des enfants surdoués
avec tes adultes surdoué et je me suis
rendu compte que les surtout et je ne
les connaissais pas et peu de gens et
hbos par notre climat et peu de gens les
connais peu de gens les connaissent et
ça m'embêtait beaucoup alors aujourd'hui
je vous fais ce talk pour vous présenter
un peu comment fonctionnent les surdoué
pour vous piquer votre curiosité je veux
pas avoir matériellement le temps de
vous présenter tout ce qui est être un
surdoué
j'ai décidé de vous sélectionné trois
points précis qui pour moi explique
beaucoup de choses chef surdoué et
permettent ensuite de comprendre un
maximum de choses
si jamais vous êtes intéressés par le
sujet je vous invite à lire le livre
trop intelligent pour être heureux ce
livre est super il explique tout sur les
surdoués si jamais vous voulez vous
renseigner avant toute chose avant de
présenter un peu ce que c'est qu'être un
surdoué génétiquement et sait faire des
petites présentations et ensuite vous
expliquer un petit peu je tiens à
commencer par quelque chose
par définition un surdoué ça peut pas
être prétentieux ça peut pas être
méprisant pourquoi parce qu'un lucidi un
surdoué et j'espère que vous le
comprendrez à la fin de ce talk c'est
très lucide sur le monde sur les gens
sur les choses mais c'est aussi très
lucide sur lui même et donc le surdoué
capte toutes ces erreurs tous ses
défauts toutes ces incapacité à faire
des choses et c est donc bah le surdoué
et en étant conscient de toutes ces
erreurs de toutes ces points noirs
il est jamais sûr de lui et donc il
n'est jamais prétentieux parce que
chaque fois que j'ai fait ce talk on a
réussi à me dire des fois que ce talk et
est prétentieux alors s'il vous plaît
n'interprétez pas ça s'est passé à un
surdoué est impossible c'est impossible
qu'il soit prétentieux alors tout
d'abord qu'est ce que c'est qu'un train
sur deux un surdoué par définition
scientifique c'est un une personne
enfant ou adulte qui a un quotient
intellectuel supérieur à 130 pourquoi
130 parce que c'est à deux écarts types
de la moyenne qui est de 100 lorsque
vous avez 132 cuit vous avez un quiz
supérieur à 98 % de la population c'est
pour ça qu'on dit que le surdoué a un
bon potentiel intellectuel qi supérieur
et tous ces maux qui défavorise
vachement le surdoué à l'heure actuelle
il est impossible encore de dire s'il
assure devance est acquise ou si elle
est innée si elle est héréditaire ou non
héréditaire souvent en entendant ça
entend dire que si le père est surdoué
alors l'enfant est souvent surdoué ou la
mer et surtout et c'est rien n'est
prouvé tout prouve tout et prouver par
des études alors je déciderai de rien
vous présenter tout est possible là je
vais rentrer dans le dans le cerveau le
cerveau c'est ce qui explique un peu les
différences au niveau de fonctionnement
au niveau du surdoué chez le surdoué ya
deux parties du cerveau qui fonctionne
différemment ce que chez les non surdoué
il ya le cortex préfrontal et
l'hémisphère droit
tout d'abord commençons par le cortex
préfrontal le cortex préfrontal c'est du
lieu du langage c'est le lieu du
raisonnement analytique de la mémoire de
travail et il est peut-être parti est
plus développée chez le surdoué che non
sur deux souvent on a tendance à croire
que plus intelligent meilleur
fonctionnement c'est parce qu'il ya plus
de neurones eh bien c'est faux qui
change c'est la ramification neuronale
et la vitesse de connexion entre les
neurones en effet les neurones sont
connectés partout dans le cerveau chez
surdoué et en plus pour vous donner un
chiffre et scientifique la vitesse de
connexion de la vitesse de transmission
d'informations par les neurones et
fonction du qi à chaque point de cui
l'information va à 0 05 mètres par
seconde plus rapidement donc vous
imaginez avec 10 points de cuillé et
c'est que l'information à l'échelle du
cerveau ça va très très vite et donc ça
m'amène à vous présenter le premier
point parce que le surdoué quand il à
132 cuit les informations vont très très
vite et à un moment donné les
informations dans le cerveau vont
tellement vite qu'elles sont
incontrôlables et donc le surdoué à une
hyperactivité cérébrale c'est comme si
vous aviez une roue infernale qui tourne
et tournez tournez tournez tournez et
qu'il fallait en permanence arrêté
contrôler et si vous avez le malheur de
ne pas l'arrêter une demi seconde
elles retournent à leur tourner à
l'automne comme un bruit toulouse qui
prend le dessus sur la vie pour vous
donner un exemple qui va peut-être vous
étonner il est pas rare enfin s'il est
peut-être armés il arrive souvent qu'on
rencontre à l'hôpital des gens qui se
sont martelés la tête sur un mur qui se
sont martelés la tête sur
avec un marteau et on leur demande mais
pourquoi vous avez fait ça ils vous
disent je pensais trop je pouvais
fallait que ça s'arrête fallait que
j'arrête les pensées c'était plus
possible c'était invivable et souvent se
rend compte que ces personnes sondées
sur dix savent explique aussi le
scientifique le savant qui marchent la
tête en l'air et qui tombe dans un puits
je sais pas si vous connaissez cette
anecdote parce que quand les pensées
prennent le dessus sur ce que le sur la
vie du surdoué et bah il est dans ses
pensées dans les airs souvent je sais
pas si vous connaissez ce cette
impression c'est quand vous avez quand
ça fait vous vous rendez compte que ça
fait vingt minutes que vous regardez
dans le vide que vous êtes sous la
douche et que vous étiez dans vos
pensées et ben le surdoué si koné qui
contrôle pas ses pensées c'est sa vie en
permanence et donc vous avez des
personnes en face de vous qui pense tout
le temps qu'ils peuvent pas contrôler
leurs pensées et qui sont et ses pensées
sont omniprésentes deuxième point de
céder ramifications neuronale
différentes dans le cortex préfrontal
c'est que le penser les surdoués pense
en arborescence alors qu'est-ce que ses
pensées en arborescence par exemple je
vous donnais l'entité si le surdoué
pense à un bateau il va voir le bateau
il va voir la voile il va voir le tissu
il va voir le pimpant il va voir son
pantalon il va voir la dernière soirée
qu'il a fait avec son pantalon il va
voir les gens danser à cette soirée ta
ta ta ta ta ta ta et puis avec la
vitesse neuronale qui va très très vite
tout au tout au tout et au final à quoi
pensaient au départ
et ça c'est une réalité c'est que la
pension d'arborescence du surdoué fait
que le surdoué se perd en permanence
dans ses pensées
c'est ça qui explique aussi si vous
connaissez peut-être ça que les enfants
surdoués
souvent ils voient l'exercice il voit
l'énoncé de l'exercice
il réalise les iris a donné la réponse à
exercice sans être capable d'expliquer
leur cheminement et donc c'est pour ça
que souvent ils sont en échec scolaire
les enfants sur des c'est parce qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à suivre le raisonnement
logique qui leur permet d'amener à la
réponse est donc vous avez des gens qui
pensent très très vite et qui n'arrivent
pas à suivre le cours de leur pensée et
c'est souvent pour ça qu'on associe le
terme de surdoué au terme de troubles de
l'attention et c'est pour ça que des
fois on peut même parler de handicap au
niveau du sud et parce que pour vous
donner un ordre d'idée j'en discutais
avec un enfant notre foi et il
m'expliquait que quand il voyait un camp
y voyez une mouche face à l'année très
vite aux vacances et du coup qu'il
partait dans vacances et du coup ils
étaient plus dans le court et skill
réveiller c'était le top top top du
professeur qu il réveillait parce qu'il
était dans ses pensées parce que la
mouche la mouche qui vole qui veulent
l'avion etc et hop en avion il se
retrouve en vacances et donc la sueur du
gospel amené fera peut être un trouble
de l'attention
et enfin ce qu'il ya aussi qu'ils aient
enfin troisième point qui diffère chez
surdoué c'est que surdoué les nissarts
droit du surdoué fonctionne beaucoup
plus que l'hémisphère gauche
parra fonctionne plus enterrer les plus
développés que les mais faire un
cauchemar
ce qui fait les demi-soeurs droit c'est
l'hémisphère des sentiments et donc
l'hémisphère droit en fait il va arrêter
le fonctionnement de son cerveau pour
les séparent à vos sentiments
et donc ce qui fait que le surdoué il
est hyper il est hyper réceptif
émotionnellement et donc puisqu'il est
hyper réceptif émotionnellement tout
pour lui et sujet à réaction
émotionnelle extrêmement forte
par exemple on veut donner un ordre
d'idée j'ai un ami dans la salle qui un
jour m'a dit t'es lourd
j'ai mis trois jours à m'en remettre et
je dormais pas de la nuit pendant trois
jours et souvent on dit mémé laisser mes
edouard mais même les surdoué en général
mais relativisée c'est pas grave mais on
peut pas faire autrement de par ce
système de pensée qui tourne qui tourne
quittons s est hyper réceptivité
émotionnel au final tout tout est pris
comme ça et donc vous avez en face de
vous bilan des trois choses vous avez en
face de vous des gens qui sont hyper
lucide de par leur pensée en
arborescence et c est donc un sur deux
qu'est ce que ça fait ça se lève le
matin et en permanence à analyses autour
de lui tout ce que les gens font ces
prix émotionnellement ça rentre dans la
pensée en arborescence ça rentre dans la
pensée dans la pensée dans la roue
infernale et toto tu as tout le temps
tout en tout temps tout le temps et donc
c'est très fatigant c'est très fatigant
parce que le surdoué en permanence il
doit ce côté il doit être à l'école et
se concentrer dans l'école du coup il va
se concentrer et du coup il arrêtait ses
pensées qui sont énormes et rossens ils
ont toujours entre qui sont toujours en
train de l'emmener ailleurs
en plus de ça à chaque petit événement
bas émotionnellement ça va travailler ça
va le faire bouger ça va le faire se
sentir mal du coup il va être concentrée
sur le fait de se sentir mal et donc il
va pas être concentré du coup il va pas
arrêter sa roue infernale et si jamais
vous vous voyez ce que vous voyez l'idée
est à eux
et donc vous avez face à vous aurez des
gens qui des gens qui on ne sait
peut-être pas mais qui sont en
souffrance et les gens ne savent pas ça
est donc d'abord ces trois points là et
que ce explique beaucoup de choses du
surdoué ça explique que de par cette
lucidité bas quand le terme de la mort
rentrer dans sa pensée bas vous imaginez
bien que vers où ça peut amener la mort
et du coup que c'est très très grande
lucidité sur la mort ça fait ça fait que
surdoué a très peur de la mort c'est
quand de l'aider quand les erreurs
rentrer dans le raisonnement du surdoué
bas ça devient tout de suite énorme du
coup le surdoué extrêmement
perfectionniste et il est rentré dans
une espèce de crise existentielle de la
vie tellement il est lucide sur
l'inutilité de tout ce qui fait et donc
et donc oui le discours est très lourd
je vous présente un discours qui est
très lourd pour vous marquez un petit
peu mais pour conclure dessoude enfin
des solutions existent par exemple pour
moi ça a été le sport et la méditation
sama book ça aide beaucoup à
extérioriser cet excédent de pensées et
voilà j'espère que que vous comprenez un
peu mieux comment fonctionne un surdoué
à l'heure actuelle et j'espère avoir
attisé notre curiosité parce que les
surdoués sont des personnes en
souffrance et mérite d'être connu voilà
[Applaudissements]